[Musique]
camel bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui dans la du château de
versaill et nous allons parler d'un
futur événement qui va se produire pour
la 2e année consécutive à savoir le bal
masasqué du château de Versailles donc
vous êtes à nouveau le chorégraphe c'est
bien exact oui oui je je suis le
chorégraphe le mteur en scène de ce ce
bal incroyable ouis même si c'est la
deuxième fois pour moi je le vis
vraiment comme une expérience unique
c'est c'est quand même juste incroyable
et à chaque fois que je suis ici j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion parce que
voilà on sent l'âme du passé on sent les
lieux sont imprgés les lieux sont
impréignés et puis voilà puis d'investir
ses lieux dans d'en faire une histoire
d'aujourd'hui c'est moi c'est c'est
c'est un Paris que que vous avez envie
de relever avec bonheur si je peux me
permettre voilà de finir bon j'aimerais
bien qu'on monte un tout petit peu en
arrière parce que votre carrière de
danseur vous avez commencé comme danseur
je me trompe pas oui tout à fait assez
jeune très jeune très jeune à quel âge
vous avez commencé la danse la danse mes
premiers cours j'avais 11 ans ouais et
professionnellement j'ai commencé à
travailler à 15 ans si tôt oui très tôt
ouais comment ça se fait alors vous
avez inégé une troupe ou comment ça
s'est passé B en fait les choses se sont
faites un peu comme ça un peu par hasard
déjà moi déjà la la danse c'était pas
quelque chose auquel j'avais pensé
j'avais pas du tout pensé à refaire mon
métier et même aller prendre un cours de
danse et voilà j'ai été prendre un
premier cours de danse grâce à ma sœur
c'est votre sœur qui vous entraîné parce
qu'elle faisait de la danse c'est ça
d'cord et puis à la fin du coup cours je
dis ben voilà j'ai envie d'en faire mon
métier puis à 15 ans ouais tout de suite
coup de cœur ouais coup de cœurro et à
mon professeur de danse Guito qui a 15
ans quand moi j'avais 15 ans décide de
de de partir de quitter La Courneuve où
où elle enseigné dans dans dans une MJC
et où je prenais des cours et puis et le
le le directeur dit mais qui va vous
remplacer je faisais pas partie des
avancées et mais à la grande surprise de
tout le monde a dit bah je pense que la
personne qui ser la mieux pour me
remplacer c'est camel et vous aviez quel
âge à l'époque là j'avais 15 ans et je
commençais déjà un petit peu à danser un
peu en dehors aussi et puis en fait tout
s'est fait très très vite j'ai j'ai
chorégraphié à 16 ans Marien caré j'ai
voilà j'ai j'ai fait c'est fulgurant
comme carrière ça a été très rapide très
très rapide et sur des projets
complètement fous et complètement
différents parce que autant j'ai
chorégraphier Maria caré autant j'ai été
passé une audition à mes 18 ans pour le
Béjar Balet où j'ai fait non pas laanne
c'était à Paris c'était pour la dernière
représentation de de George don avec le
Bolero Dravel et et j'ai dansé dedans
voilà il plein de trucs par hasard voilà
et vous avez attrapé les Chan au fur à
mesure o elle se présentait et voilà le
résultat ouais voilà vous avez été donc
professeur vous après donc chorégraphe
metteur en scène vous avez aussi été le
le professeur bien connu de la Star
Académie tout à fait voilà vous l'avez
fait plusieurs années ben j'ai fait
toutes
toutes les années ça a durait combien de
temps je me souviens plus 8 ans de
starac 8 ans de starac où je faisais
plein plein plein d'autres choses en
même temps bien sûr parce que OK et
après alors vous avez monté de de grands
spectacles qu'on peut nommer comme ça
autant on emporte le vent cléopâre euh
m'aidez pas surtout le Roi Soleil le
voilà mon lien formidable le Roi Soleil
cléopadreopadre et pu des opéras que
j'ai mis en scène aussi Hel châelet
voilà plein de projets différents et et
dans lesqueles je prends plein plein de
plaisir toujours toujours et vous
travaillez toujours à ce rythme effrainé
en enchaînant les en France à l'étranger
ouais et vous êtes surtout aux
États-Unis ou pas spécialement pas
partout partout partout ça peut être en
Europe ça peut être en Algérie ça peut
être voilà je chaque projet m'emmène
ailleurs et ça c'est très excitant pour
moi parce qu'à chaque fois c'est des
aventures humaines avec des gens qui ont
des cultures aussi différentes mais à
chaque fois je suis quand même très
content d'être en France c'est vrai
ouais et ch fois amourux de la France
oui je pense qu'elle vous rend bien et
dites-moi vous avez une école de danse
si on peut dire ou une TR non non
j'enseigne pas la danse j'enseigne pas
du tout je suis pas du tout professeur
parce que j'ai arrêté très vite parce
que pour moi un professeur il doit être
assidu vraiment être vous allez dire
ass non non non et et c'est vrai que moi
en sachant que je tourne beaucoup à
l'étranger ou c'est pas possible puis
voilà puis voilà mon terrain de
prédilection c'est quand même la mise en
scène et la chorégraphie ok donc l'année
dernière vous avez assuré la mise en
scène et la chorégraphie du bal masqué
pour la première fois
ici et la scénographie pardon il en a
tellement que ouou en fait non parce que
moi ça ça m'intéresse vraiment parce que
c'est vrai que de de savoir que voilà de
de de de décider que la déco ça sera
comme ça parce que c'est un fil
conducteur pour tout en en fait vous
faites la conception de l'ensemble de
l'ensemble du bal ouais après je suis
très entouré il y a une très grosse
équipe mais oua ou ouais qui sont super
puis ça VO c'est c'est un travail étroit
avec toute l'équipe du château voilà
toute l'équipe spectacle du
château c'est aussi un travail étroit
avec avec Joël Le le le chef jardinier
voilà c'est c'est vraiment des
rencontres qui sont qui sont super h
vous commencez à vous sortir chez vous
là maintenant au château de versaill
vous avez vous refaire puisque vous
recommencez donc là le 28 juin le 28
juin mais pour moi c'est vraiment déjà
je je je repars sur à zéro que les gens
vont vivre une même même les gens qui
sont venus l'année dernière rien qu'en
arrivant ici ils vont comprendre que
c'est un autre bal je recrée cette année
une je fais une version contemporaine de
la de la galerie des Glaces donc c'est
un un un mélange entre la galerie des
glaces qui a rencontré coctto qui a
rencontré camel Wally et parce que je je
mets des miroirs dans toutes ces ces
sublimes Alcor inclinés comme ça pour
moi je voulais que les les les convives
soient aussi euh Fass qu'
l'interactivité entre le convive qui VAE
partie du spectacle finalement il va se
voir qu'il soit acteur complètement donc
euh donc voilà je il y a un côté
fantastique que j'aime beaucoup bon mais
ça promet d'être merveilleux et alors il
y a il y a des danseurs j'imagine
professionnels qui sont là sur les
scènes ou sur la scène il y a une grande
scène il y a une très grande scène où
j'ai fait un spectacle à 360 parce que
les gens sont un peu partout voilà et
puis puis a différentes scènes à
différents endroits parce que j'aime
bien aussi que que il y ait des choses
qui se passent que tout le monde ne voit
pas euh voilà auss rendez-vous tiétais
là j'ai vu ça non Mo j'étaisautre côté
j'ai vu autre chose il y a y a vraiment
j'ai 60 artistes qui euh dans qui danse
qui chante il y a des artistes de cirque
j'ai voilà j'ai des comédi oui c'est
hper complet oui oui c'est pas juste de
la danse parce que moi je pensais bal je
pensais dans non non il y a de tout il y
a de tout c'est vraiment je pense que
les gens vont être surpris j'accueille
moi les convives à partir de de 23h
avant ils ont la chance de pouvoir
assister au grandes nocturnes OK et à
partir de 23h il y a déjà moi je mets
déjà en scène l'entrée à l'Orangerie
donc il y a déjà plein de choses qui se
passent à l'extérieur il va avoir un
aquarium géant avec des des des des
femmes sirènes à l'intérieur il va y
avoir des chevaux qui déambulent dans
les allées il va y avoir plein plein de
choses ouais c'est énorme je m'éclate ah
ext et vous alors est-ce que vous serez
déguisé mais moi je serais déglisé puis
de toute façon c'est obligatoire tout le
monde doit être costumé masqué en pour
quoi je sais pas encore j'ai plusieurs
options j'ai pas encore choisi et
l'année dernière vous étiez en quoi al
l'année dernière j'étais j'étais un
personnage alors j'étais pas baroque du
tout j'étais j'étais plutôt un peu
fantastique parce que parce que j'avais
envie de ça alors là peut-être je serai
plus baroque peut-être cette année je
serai le roi soleil enfin enfin enfin
votre vraie place c'est ça non non je ne
serai pas le RO le roi soleille mais non
je sais pas encore ce que je serai
j'aurai un beau cost
ouaisost très costum non mais en plus
c'est hallucinant les gens il il ils ont
des costumes incroyables des masques
incroyables c'est le spectacle c'est eux
aussi c'est pour ça tout alors vous
parlez d'acteur le public acteur parce
que ils ont des des des costumes
merveilleux mais des costumes
merveilleux euh et puis les gens voilà
les gens on sent qu'il passe un moment
unique et incroyable il y a des gens qui
viennent du monde entier alors justement
c'est ça que je voulais savoir quels
sont les les les participants à ce bal
au niveau du public vous avez une idée
ou pas oui oui on le sait ououi on le
sait bon il y a beaucoup de version ça y
est bien sûr heureusement quand
même après bon il y a des gens qui
viennent de de toute la France mais
aussi d'Australie d'Asie de Corée du
Japon il y a des gens qui viennent de
partout partout partout et ça c'est
extraordinaire ouais c'est fantastique
et et ça réunit à peu près combien de
personnes au niveau du du public je
pense que c'est entre 2005 et 3000
personnes ça contient l'Orangerie
contient 3000 personnes on sera complet
on sera complet voilà on sera complet et
donc la fête commence donc avec les e
les EAU nocturnes les grandes e mais je
sa pas qu ça commence exactement je sais
pas si c'est 22h ou 21h30 et puis après
donc là moi je les emmène faire la fête
ici ou donc c'est sur de la musique pop
ça il faut le dire quand même c'est
important parce que l'année dernière
c'était quoi comme musique non c'était
musique pop aussi je prend les plus gros
DJ par oui c'est ça donc c'est la
musique contemporaine complètement et et
après il y a aussi les afters dans le
dans les jardins il y a petit déjeuner
offert dans les jardin de de Versailles
du château de versaill avec DJ musique
et tout on fait la fête jusqu on mit pas
ah non non non on fait la fête jusqu'
jusqu'à 10h jusqu'à 10h du matin ok bon
ben écoutez ça va être une nuit
merveilleuse hein il faut il fa et vous
vous serez costumé comment je vous dirai
pas d'accord mais vous verrez ça va être
super j'imagine bon merci beaucoup camel
nous avoir donné de votre précieux temps
au 28 juin avec plaisir et puis
peut-être après pour d'autres projets
qui sait ah bah il faut il faut on en
reparle merci avec plaisirci au
revoir
[Musique]